okie-dokie time to watch movie gotta
pick one I haven't seen before where do
I want to watch great movie The Wicker
Man starring Nicolas Cage it's a creepy
looking girl with white eyes clearly she
will be featured in the film at some
point I'm sure that well Nicolas Cage is
in it so it's a hundred percent
guaranteed to be good
I think I'll watch this
okay look whoa yeah I've been standing
here for about a minute hoping that my
stupid idiotic past self would somehow
make the right choice but I was reminded
that I didn't I'm from the future
two years in the future in fact and I am
warning you do not watch The Wicker Man
whoa whoa I'm still wearing the same
shirt two years from now you know I
really do need a wardrobe change don't I
that's besides the point dude listen to
me listen to me don't watch this movie
listen to yourself don't watch The
Wicker Man you will regret it I'm trying
to erase it from our memory hold on we
have time travel two years from now yes
actually you can get it at Walmart for
about three hundred ninety six dollars
and 96 cents I probably shouldn't be
telling you this
hmm I don't like what I make that face
what I make that face I get into trouble
if time-travel gets invented in two
years and I probably shouldn't do
anything different right otherwise it
might not get invented yes then I'm
gonna watch it please don't watch it I'm
gonna watch it don't watch it I'm gonna
put it in the blu-ray player I am
begging you please don't watch that
movie I'm gonna watch it fine it's your
fear it's our funeral fantastic have a
great day
geeze future me is really paranoid what
could possibly be wrong with a Nicolas
Cage movie called The Wicker Man I mean
it's obviously going to be good it's
guaranteed to be good it will be good
there is absolutely no doubt in my mind
this movie's going to be good it has to
be good
it starts Nicolas Cage oscar-winning
actor it will be good
why is future me so dumb if I drown
myself in the river in the woods outside
you think they'd find my body The Wicker
Man starring Nicolas Cage a truly awful
movie but it's awful in a very special
way it is hilariously awful it is such
an atrocity that it is hilarious it's
officially a hilarious 'ti so let's talk
about it today on my hilarious 'ti
review of The Wicker Man starring the
one and only Nicolas Cage I did not hit
her it's not true it's bullshit I did
not hit her I did not oh hi mark hi
the wicker man they don't get funnier
than this guys they honestly they just
don't this is one of the best bad movies
ever made now my last hilarious T review
was for the room I've gotten a lot of
requests ever since then to do more and
I was thinking to myself Nicolas Cage
has made a lot of movies that could fit
in with that hilariously title quite a
bit there were a few that I could have
done there's vampires kiss it's a
horrible horrible job and you have to do
it you have to or I'll fire you do you
understand
I never misfiled anything not once not
one time my fiancee literally just came
to the door and asked me if everything
was alright and you can't forget con air
why couldn't you put the button back in
the box Nicolas Cage is awesome I gotta
be honest I love the guy even in a bad
movie he entertains me I can't help it I
love the guy he seems cool in real life
also
whatever he's awesome however the Wicker
Man is a horrible movie let's talk about
it the first time I saw this movie I was
in disbelief at how bad it was because
it's marketed as this extremely scary
thriller it supposed to be a very scary
horror movie that's really supposed to
disturb you and that's really one of the
goals Nicolas Cage had when he set out
to remake this movie he wanted to make a
very disturbing movie that would haunt
our dreams it did in certain ways but
probably not the ways that he was hoping
so the movie opens with him buying some
self-help tapes why is he doing this we
don't really know it's never referenced
again in the movie even one time it's a
very simple and easy way to explain to
us that he's not terribly happy except
when he picks up the tape he smiles like
who picks up a self-help Tim goes yeah
this sounds like fun no one happily buys
self-help tapes self-help tapes over
depressed people you're not happy if you
buy one of those the Nicolas Cage's and
then we cut to another scene that is the
most reference and constantly shown
scene in this movie that absolutely has
nothing to do with the movie whatsoever
so this truck comes along driving on the
complete 100% opposite side of the road
doesn't see the car there or the police
officer and decides to crash into the
car and kill everybody and ruin
everyone's day then the main title comes
up and it's a scene that is constantly
constantly referenced throughout this
movie you see him in vis
this little girl when he's on a boat you
see like a truck hit a girl out of
nowhere there is no reason for this
scene it's never just the scene that's
in the movie one time but it said there
would be like five times later for no
reason at all why so we cut the Nicolas
Cage in his home and a fellow police
woman brings him some letters he reads
these letters and one of them is from an
old flame and she is speaking like she
is right out of M night Shyamalan's the
village I wanted to send you this letter
in private because I had to give you
this letter and it meant so much to me
oh my dear Nicolas Cage you know what
she sounds like
Olga Pataky from the Hey Arnold Show
that's right the older sister of Helga
that's what she sounds like Oh baby
sister I just love you so much
Wow I can imitate her I never realized
that it till just out that's not really
something to brag about I guess so Nick
Cage does some research on this summer's
isle place they have a website they have
a website this place has a website later
in the movie you find out they don't
have any phones on the island they got a
website though this girl is missing her
daughter and she needs his help because
he cares about her still these two have
thing going on he decides to go out
there and find this girl that also
reminds me the fact that when he gets
the letter he gets an unknown phone call
from somebody and it really freaks him
out okay so who's the phone call from
they don't have phones on this island
supposedly who's calling him we never
find out it doesn't I guess it doesn't
really matter now when he gets to
summers Isle he runs into this group of
old and incredibly unattractive women
who are holding a bloody bag and he asks
the first natural question that any of
us would ask in this situation what's in
the bag a shark or something yeah of
course it's a shark I mean what else
would be in a bag a shark of course I
mean we all carry sharks around in bags
don't we that's just what people do so
cage walks into the neighborhood bar and
there's a woman behind the counter she's
technically a woman she looks more like
a man but she's a woman he kills a B on
the table and that's apparently like
blasphemy in this place we'll learn more
about bees later that's a very important
part of this movie but at the doorway
appears his old flame with lips
three times the size of your average
woman someone's had some injections she
stands there looking like a heroin
addict and she pretty much looks like a
heroin addict throughout the majority of
this movie generally every single scene
with her has her start speaking and then
just stop like mid-sentence she really
likes to say sentences and then just
stop and not finish it she does it
literally I swear it's like all she does
she'll be like well what that's all she
does in the movie
okay so later on in the movie cages in
beds sleeping and we get the obligatory
dream sequence it seems to come with all
these stupid horror movies where you
have a character dreaming about
something that maybe is slightly
integral to the plot except in this
movie he dreams about the truck accident
again which I have already said has
nothing to do with the plot it's just
this scene they keep referencing over
and over again for no reason to have
Nicolas Cage have something to be
stressed out about so we can really want
some self-help tapes wow this is the
perfect dive room to bust out that
self-help tape right the one that he
bought in the very first scene in the
movie that must have some kind of
importance no of course not he's not
gonna do anything with that ever why
would you think that maybe they put that
scene in the movie so they could show
him wake up and look out the window and
see the little girl running down there
he sees the girl he's like wow there's
the girl I'm gonna go chase her it was
like someone was like hey we probably
have to have something in this movie
that's even remotely thrilling okay
we'll have Nicolas Cage like hanging
from a piece of wood so after that
random scene of him just running around
at night we don't really find anything
it doesn't lead to anything we meet
legally sobieski x' character yes I
remember that actresses name sorry I
just I remember things it's a weird
scene of awkward sexual tension that has
no purpose she keeps asking him to take
her with him when he leaves and he's
like yeah I know now as I say all these
things I can't help but think about the
things that happen later in the movie
and I know how this movie ends and I
can't help but think about how none of
this makes sense I'll get to that later
I will don't worry now there's a part in
this movie that I actually start to kind
of seriously relate to Nicolas Cage's
character and that's because what this
movie does is it pits men against women
the original Wicker Man was more about
Catholicism versus paganism that's more
disturbing the whole sexist battle thing
isn't really ground
for this type of horror movie so at some
point in this movie Nicolas Cage's
character actually starts to do what the
audience is thinking like there are
certain moments in the film like when
the kids raise their hand and go
battle-ax in both phallic symbol he just
starts laughing and I'm like yeah that's
that's how I feel - man don't worry
about it I feel yet within that same
scene he opens up a desk and a bird
flies out and he goes he trapped a
little bird inside see how long he can
stand it now why in the hell would you
let them do a sick thing like that yeah
that's that's exactly what I was
thinking - man I agree with you and
that's what I'm saying there's a point
this movie where Nicolas Cage's
character starts to say what the
audience is feeling and it's like we are
speaking through him and that's kind of
what a main character supposed to do in
a movie but in this movie I just really
do relate to his character at a point in
this movie because if there's a poor way
he's just like dude what in the hell is
this all about man I don't get any of
this it's weird and that's how I feel as
an audience member so Nic Cage and the
girl with the giant lips are talking and
she finally admits that the girl they've
been searching for is actually their
daughter it's like wow I really didn't
see that I definitely saw it coming a
long time ago but her performance is
just just looks like a crack head
throughout every scene in this movie
it's like they got her all shot up with
drugs or something and she can't stop
making incomplete sentences it's all she
does in the movie is incomplete
sentences so like I said there's a point
this movie where Nicholas Cage starts to
get just about as annoyed as we are as
characters like doesn't give a crap
anymore he even starts to interrupt
characters that we are annoyed with she
can swim like like sunshine okay um I
legitimately like that about this movie
how is characters just at a point like I
don't care anymore just just leave me
alone
God you people are really annoying so
Nic Cage sees the old guy come back into
plain the old guy a man another man me
Amelia's like I have to go find this man
I have to run to him because there are
so many crazy women on this island get
me out of here now in the one to two
minute radius it takes for him to run
down to the dock the old elderly woman
have already taken out the pilot as well
as the radio and all of the controls
those are some magical speed powers
those elderly whim
and half pretty impressive then he sees
the girl under the docks and he's like I
got to go down there and get her and
then he wakes up it's another dream
another dream the first dream sequence
earlier in the movie was like the
obligatory dream sequence of the horror
movie we have a second one now when he
wakes up from the second dream guess
what he's not actually up he's still
dreaming again another dream sequence
another one enough for the dream
sequences so later in the movie he's
spying on this old lady who's leaving
her house as the Emperor's Royal Guards
from Return of the Jedi follow her
everywhere she goes so after he breaks
into her house he finds some fetuses in
jars a staple of any horror film you
gotta have a fetus in a jar or you might
just be making a really good horror
movie that doesn't follow the stupid
cliche of the fetus inside the jar so
next we get to meet the ultimate old hag
of all the old hags this is apparently
the queen of summers Isle I don't know
what she is she's like the queen bee
maybe I'm in a bee Joe and he starts to
ask her some questions that were pretty
much wandering ourselves as audience
members were like yeah yeah exactly man
and the film script doesn't have any
idea how to answer his question so she
goes come on let's wander and then it
just cuts to some scene and then
wandering around she's saying random
things I don't actually answer any of
his questions or any of our questions so
basically you learned that men in this
place are only viewed as possible
breeders that's what we men do for these
women in the wicker man colony of
summers Isle we breed you can tell that
none of the men have any education as
well they're all like like Nicolas Cage
bumps into one like Nicolas Cage bumps
into one of them and he's it goes like
they don't know how to speak hardly at
all they're just like worker bees
another bee pun Oh so later on he hears
a random girl like crying inside a crypt
and he's thinking wow that could be the
girl so he goes down there and tries to
find her and they trap him there and he
gets trapped there all night in like
neck high water what's the purpose of
this I don't know if there was a
semblance of a story this movie might be
possibly good I really want to bring up
the stupid part of this movie that I
hate the most but I gotta wait to the
end to make it as powerful as possible
but I'm remembering all this stuff I'm
remembering everything I mentioned so
far remembering them trapping him down
there at night
almost drowning remembering all that so
I can bring it up at the end of the
review and bring all this home I'll get
to it don't worry so now we have one of
the best scenes in the whole movie once
Nicolas Cage is freed from this trap he
is pretty freakin mad and wet and mad
and extremely mad and he really wants to
know how this thing in his hands got
burned
how'd it get burned how'd it get burned
how'd it get burned out of your burn
Mike don't know I just I loved that
scene so much now we've come to what I
call the WTF house because every door
the Nicolas Cage opens in this house
that's pretty much what you say in your
head I mean there's girls covered in
bees old fat men covered in bee stings
in here and it's just like every door
has a great surprise behind it what's
behind door number one Johnny an old fat
man with bee stings yeah now this point
Nicolas Cage is really starting to break
I mean he's even telling people to get
off bicycles at gunpoint and it's pretty
awesome when he does it I'm telling you
I get off that bicycle if you talk to me
like that
get off the bike step away from the bike
take a stupid mask so later on he finds
the old pilot he's got no eyes he's got
no hands his mouth is sewn shut what
does he try to do wake him up yeah he
might have been alive so I'm thinking as
a viewer who killed the airplane guy
well we get a scene explaining that
perfectly this old lady who looks like
she's about 85 years old is like I took
care of that business down there yes I
did
oh so you kill them okay lady you need a
bar by your toilet so you can get up
from it after you take a crap there's no
way you're gonna kill some guy so his
mouth shut
cut out his eyeballs cut off his hands
in the two minutes it took Nicolas Cage
to run down to that plane it ain't
happening lady but it doesn't really
matter you know why cuz Nicolas Cage
can't take it anymore
he just can't take these women anymore
he's done he snapped he's lost it and
he's done with these ladies Nicolas has
been let out of the cage ladies and
gentlemen he can't take it anymore
these ladies are going down now the next
scene in this movie is indescribable I
can't describe the Nicolas Cage bear
suit scene the only way I can think to
show just how crazy the scene is is to
show you somebody watching it for the
first time having no idea what they're
about to see
so I filmed my fiance watching the bear
suit scene
for the very first time please enjoy her
reaction what are you thinking that huh
they actually made that into a movie yes
they did through you who said Nicholas
Cage should wear a bear suit and run
around and punch a girl whoever did
thank you man cuz that's the funniest
thing I've ever seen in my life
and then another display of incredible
speed powers as shown as this group of
about a hundred people go all the way
around a forest the Nicolas Cage is
cutting through this forest and somehow
they beat him I don't know how but they
do and then we get the giant twist
explained to us and of course it's
explained in a very detailed fashion for
us dumb audience members who are too
stupid to figure anything out on our own
why respect us and allow us to figure
things out with great visual
storytelling when you can have an old
hag goddess lady explain the entire
thing to us while she wears her
Braveheart paint so apparently the
entire scheme behind this thing is they
needed somebody who was in some way
blood related to someone on the island
come to that Island at his own will so
they could then sacrifice him hopefully
getting their honey crop back someone
wrote that down and said that's a good
idea
and then hundreds of other people said
yeah I like that that's a good idea more
importantly after each take in this
movie somebody in the background said
cut print I like that one who said that
okay so as I kept hinting throughout
this video I'm gonna bring this whole
thing around the thing I hate most about
this movie is the fact that none of it
makes sense
the accident the truck scene nothing to
do with the movie the self-help tapes
nothing to do with the movie okay now we
know that they want to kill him they
want to sacrifice him he is their only
hopeful thing for this honey crop to
come back
so why did they trap him underground at
night where he nearly drowned that would
have ruined their whole sacrifice thing
wouldn't it how about right there in the
opening scene in the movie where he
comes and looks at the shark bag there's
a whole bunch of those old women with
evil speed powers they killed that old
guy in Seoul shut his mouth and cut off
his eyes and his hands so why not kill
Nicholas Cage right there does have to
be on this stupid harvest date I guess
so but seriously why go through all this
rigmarole why all the fake stories why
all the lies why the setup why is
everyone going through this crazy
charade there he is on the island in the
beginning of the movie just imprison him
right there you got the old women with
the evil speed powers right in front of
him she can kill people pretty well she
ripped out of guys I sold shut his mouth
and cut off his hands remember I keep
referencing that because really how dumb
is that she's like 85 years old don't
trap him in a well at night if you're
gonna kill him these people are idiots
they are so stupid they can't even do
what they want to do successfully but
somehow it all works because they have
evil speed powers but they decide to go
through all this stuff and it's like why
because there wouldn't be a movie if
they didn't so next we get the infamous
be seen and the best lines of the entire
movie are spoken throughout the scene
but Jess you betcha killing me won't
bring back your goddamn money
ah the phrase oh my god is used a lot in
movies Nicolas Cage's The Wicker Man has
my favorite usage of it ever Oh God oh
my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
so he dies he burns alive it's terrible
and you see these women they look so
happy about it they're making these
faces like oh and you hate it because
you hate these characters it isn't
creepy or disturbing like the original
was it's just maddening and the worst
type of way The Wicker Man is a horrible
movie it is so so bad but it's also so
so funny if you guys ever get a chance
to watch this movie check it out with
some friends you will enjoy it until
next time guys I will be doing more
hilarious 'ti reviews let me know
someone you'd like to see in the
comments below and have a nice day and
know the Wicker Man guys as always
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck man iced the plot thickens
didn't even know you had a plot okay